[Music]
who were the alchemists
were they magicians concocting elixirs
and potions
were they occultist mystics with access
to secret knowledge
passed down from ancient times or were
they charlatans
tricking gullible people into believing
they could bestow riches and
immortality for the right price well
none of the above really though all of
those descriptions do carry a kernel of
truth
alchemy was a proto-scientific system
that sought to understand
transform and purify natural materials
it started in egypt when exactly no one
knows for sure
the details of egyptian alchemy are also
unknown to us
as most of the alchemical texts from
egypt have been lost
from egypt the system spread around the
old world
through china india the middle east and
europe because of this
alchemy was a diverse system changing
from location to location
as well as changing through time
different alchemists focused on
different things
in china alchemy was tied to taoism and
by extension traditional chinese
medicine
indian alchemists also focused on
medicinal alchemy
while those in the west and middle east
had different goals those of which we
will be focusing on in this video since
the details of western alchemy are known
to modern scholars
the problem with western alchemy is that
these alchemists liked to write down
all their thoughts theories and
experiments in strange codes and
creative analogies
this practice is the reason modern
scholars are still unsure exactly
of what alchemists were up to these
symbols and codes connected alchemy with
astrology
many astrological symbols and ideas were
also used in alchemical texts
seven planets for example corresponded
to seven metals the sun stood for gold
the moon for silver iron for mars tin
for jupiter
copper for venus lead for saturn and
mercury well
obviously for mercury alchemists also
subscribed to the aristotelian idea of
the four
classical elements earth fire air and
water
they eventually added three more
substances to that list
mercury sulfur and salt which they
believed were combined
to create compounds such as metals and
even the bodies of living things
all of this secrecy allegory and
mystical thought contributed
the modern view of alchemists as
sorcerers or magicians
whether alchemists used this magical
language to simply hide away their
knowledge
or if they really believed in the
spiritual and supernatural
connections to their work remains to be
seen more than likely it was a mixture
of both
okay so what do we know in general
alchemy had three main goals
the first was the transmutation of base
metals like lead
into precious metals like gold this
process was called chrysopia the second
was the manufacturer of the elixir of
life
able to stave off death as well as cure
all illnesses and
lastly the creation of an alcoholist or
a universal solvent
able to dissolve anything even gold how
they thought they could contain such a
substance eludes me
but i digress all of these goals
eventually got tied to the creation of
the philosopher's stone which we'll get
into in more detail later
it might seem strange to us in the
modern world to think of sciences as
having
tangible goals like this nowadays
sciences are simply the studies of
different natural phenomena
physics has no goals other than the
understanding of the fabric and forces
that make up our universe
obviously physics as well as all other
sciences
have plenty of practical application but
it would be strange to say that the
point of physics
was to make quantum computers so how is
it that alchemists thought these goals
were possible
did they come out of nowhere well
alchemy in the beginning didn't have
these exact goals
alchemists came from the likes of
metallurgists doctors and natural
philosophers that were simply trying to
understand the world around them
but alchemists as well as all
pre-scientific people
relied just as much if not more on the
wisdom of the past as they did on
observation
if something was written down in a book
by a smart person from long ago
those ideas would usually be taken for
granted so
alchemists were synthesizing both their
own observations and experiments
with the ideas of the likes of aristotle
and plato as well as from religious or
philosophical traditions like
christianity a good example of this
synthesis
is the transmutation of lead into gold
it seems like a far-fetched idea to us
but when metallurgists would heat metal
ore the ore would change color
and different compounds would appear in
the process we know now
that these reactions are because of the
impurities found in raw ore but
alchemists at the time
thought it was evidence of the
transformation of the material and of
course
chemical transmutation is a real and
natural phenomenon
and we see the transformation of things
in nature all the time it's no wonder
really that alchemists thought there
would be a way of using this
transformative aspect of nature to their
advantage
chrysopea was also seen as a mirror unto
the process of christian salvation
the transformation of lead into gold
mirrored the purification of a sinner
through god's grace
okay so what about this philosopher's
stone the process of creating the stone
was
varied different texts gave slightly
different instructions
with different alchemists having varied
approaches
in general it was achieved through
heating various elements together
until the combination of these elements
would go through a number of color
changes
the material would first turn black then
white then yellow
red and finally at least in theory it
would become the philosopher's stone
this stone could then be used to turn
base metals into gold by heating some of
it with said base metal
it could also be ingested by making it
into a powder and dissolving it into
wine
that process would create the elixir of
life many alchemists especially in the
late medieval period as well as in the
renaissance were obsessed with creating
the stone
the creation of it was known as the
magnum opus or
great work and it became the main goal
of later alchemists
legends would often pop up about someone
successfully creating the stone
and these stories kept the dream alive
for future alchemists
many famous scientists and philosophers
were alchemists
isaac newton the inventor of calculus
was also an
alchemist in his spare time tycho brahi
the famous astronomer was an alchemist
and robert boyle known as the father of
chemistry
was originally an alchemist alchemy was
an extremely important precursor to the
sciences of chemistry and medicine
and though it failed to reach its aims
it made very important discoveries and
inventions
chinese alchemists are credited with the
creation of gunpowder
and western alchemists discovered
sulfuric acid as well as other important
chemical compounds
alchemists made important contributions
to metallurgy ceramics glass making and
medicine
in the 15th century alchemy had grown a
bad reputation
writer chaucer and others mocked
alchemists as liars and quacks
pope john xxii as well as king henry iv
of england
made alchemy illegal alchemy was revived
in the renaissance
but in the 18th century after the
scientific revolution
alchemy once again gained a reputation
of charlatanism
after that alchemy slowly declined
modern day alchemists
who yes do exist move mostly within
esoteric or new age
circles because of this the modern view
of alchemy is generally negative
or at least it's not taken very
seriously which is a real shame
because while the science of alchemy has
been widely discredited
it should be looked on at least
historically with a bit more respect
thanks for watching
you